on sera et le tgv à 380 km heure 20h30
adolescent noir la peur dans la ville
d'atlanta espagne l'hommage de tous les
partis politiques à juan carlos
l'avocate a bien porté le revolver elle
l'a fait pour le faire du fond d'année
messieurs bonsoir c'est pas un record
que nous allons commencer n'a rien de
sportif mais il intéresse les couleurs
françaises
en effet la sncf qui a battu cet après
midi le record mondial de vitesse sur
rails un record qui lui appartenaient
déjà depuis un quart de siècle
331 km heure en 55 et bien cette fois ci
leur corps est pulvérisé 380 km heure
soit plus de cent mètres à la seconde
c'est grâce aux tv au tgv que la
performance a été réalisée cet après
midi entre saulieu étonné alors comment
ça s'est passé à quoi ça sert pour
l'usager georges leplay patrick esther
et toute leur équipe dans le train est
sur la voie vont essayer de vous fournir
le maximum d'informations 15h30 sur la
voie nouvelle paris lyon le soleil
fêlures la caténaire de la tension était
le spécialement de 25 à 29 mille volts
un petit vent les conditions
atmosphériques sont idéales
la rame tgv ligne rochelaise
autour de vitesse de 330 est un hommage
à celui qui est avec nous aujourd'hui
qu'il ya 26 ans atteint 7 vitesses dans
la voiture laboratoire ingénieurs et
techniciens scrute des dizaines
d'aiguillés étudie des centaines de
chiffres une seule défaillance et c'est
peut-être l'accident
l'année
position rouge de l'auteur du prince
15h38 après le départ
380 à leurs 105 mètres à la seconde
c'est le nouveau record du monde pour
l'établir les rapports donc en âge de
nos tristes été modifié et des roues
d'un diamètre plus grands remplacer
celle d'origine
pour être plus légère la ram a été
raccourci à cet élément les sept femmes
et six hommes en vie même modèle que la
ram commercial ce record a coûté des
millions de francs mais ces 380 km
représente la meilleure garantie de
sécurité que la sncf pourrait offrir aux
futurs passagers du tgv
le tgv qui roulera seraient contentés
venir à seulement 260 km/heure en
exploitation commerciale
de quoi être blasé comme les conducteurs
de l'exploit si vous roulez pour la
première fois 380 kilomètres heure qui
sera fait disons que c'est quand même
assez impressionnant parce que c'est une
vitesse qui n'est pas courante
on a quand même l'habitude de rouler à
260 260 380 ça fait quand même une
grosse différence
oui parce que une fois franchi le seuil
de trois champs on se rend compte que on
va effectivement assez vite assez vite
je crois qu'on peut quand même dire très
vite
mais comme dit conducteur ce n'est pas à
une vitesse qui est très courante ça va
lui en tout cas la sncf de télégrammes
de félicitations du chef de l'état et du
premier ministre
cent vingt mille morts par an en france
par le seul fait du cancer un chiffre
qui fait peur chaque fois qu'on les
nonces et nous sommes ici toujours très
prudent quand on nous dit qu'on va le
réduire grâce à tel ou tel médicament
miracle
or voilà qu'aujourd'hui une commission
mise en place par jacques barrot lé mise
la santé est présidé par le professeur
du bnia tube ghana nous apprend qu'on
peut éviter une mort sur 200 moyens
thérapeutiques nouveau dans les 25
prochaines années
simplement en organisant mieux le
dispositif actuellement en place
et d'abord professeur en harmonisant les
traitements je crois qu'il y aurait
plusieurs choses pour atteindre ce
chiffre
il faut un effort de tous poils et ford
et du public parce que beaucoup de
cancers sont dus au tabac et à l'alcool
et pour arriver à réduire de moitié
cette fréquence des cancers
il faut d'abord obtenir du public qu'il
fut moins et qu'ils boivent moins ceux
ci le premier point le deuxième point
est qu'il faut arriver à éviter un
certain nombre de cancers d'une façon
médicale nous avons appris au cours de
ces dernières années que beaucoup de
cancers étaient précédés par d'autres
affections non cancéreuse et qui
constituent le lit du cancer
on peut arriver à les détecter on peut
arriver à les traiter et invités et
éviter ainsi l'apparition ultérieure du
cancer c'est ce qu'on appelle le
traitement des lésions précancéreuses
qui est surtout valable pour certains
cancers
le concrètement pour les intimes est par
exemple cancer du col de l'utérus le
cancer du côlon et du rectum se
développe toujours sur des lésions qui
précède l'apparition du cancer et dont
le traitement permettrait d'arrêter
d'éviter l'apparition du cancer
quand la troisième et à cette troisième
étape consiste à traiter à faire le
diagnostic très précoce pour traiter
très précocement
à un moment on a un maximum de chances
de guérison alors là l'exemple plus
frappant c'est le cancer du sein
si les femmes se palper régulièrement
les seins pour y chercher une toute
petite tumeur si elle allait voir un
médecin spécialiste
et qu'elle avait une toute petite tumeur
et bien guérir est beaucoup plus de
cancers du sein qu'on en guérit actuelle
c'est la même chose par exemple pour le
cancer du côlon et du rectum
si les malades d'aller consulter
immédiatement des spécialistes dès
qu'ils avaient la moindre hémorragie par
voie anale et bien là aussi on éviterait
nommément alors vous dit aussi qu'il
faut accélérer la formation des médecins
alors oui alors ça c'est l'étape
complémentaires en dehors de cela le
cancer étant une fois diagnostiqués plus
tôt le cancer ayant motivé la
consultation du malade chez nous et ça
il faut à ce moment là que le médecin en
fasse vite le diagnostic que l'on fasse
vite un traitement content et quand je
dis le médecin là c'est en réalité toute
l'infrastructure médicale car il faut
que non seulement le médecin sonne le
malade soit bien orienté mais ensuite
kélian étaient bien orientées les
médecins qui vont traiter dispose de
toute l'infrastructure matérielle de
tous les instruments dont on a besoin et
que hills et autour d'eux tous les
sommes nécessaires pour un travail en
équipe vous laissez entendre qu'à
l'heure actuelle les médecins et 8 pas
forcément biel le malade au tout début
de la maladie que je voudrais dire c'est
qu'il existe actuellement une certaine
hétérogénéité une certaine inégalité de
la france de spawn ch il ya des régions
qui sont mieux équipées que d'autres il
y à des hôpitaux qui sont mieux équipées
d'autres il ya des cliniques qui sont
mieux équipées que d'autres est ce que
l'on veut fait monsieur barreau nous a
posé de problème que faire pour établir
une égalité des français devant le
cancer est bien pour cela il faut un
effort extrêmement important de tout le
corps médical pour s'éduquer pour
apprendre pour être constamment tenus au
courant des nouvelles techniques et il
faut de plus que ce corps médical est
constamment la possibilité d'avoir
recours aux instruments les plus
efficaces et qu'ils aient appris à
travailler en équipe
car aucun médecin solde est à l'heure
actuelle capable de traiter tous les
cancers le traitement du cancer est une
affaire d'équipé mais pour l'instant
vous dites que les centres anti cons
séance s'est re ne sont pas équipés de
la même façon selon elle
son épique ville non les centres
anticancéreux
il y en a que vers en france se sont
dans l'ensemble extrêmement bien équipé
ce que je voulais dire c'est qu'il ya un
certain il n'y a qu'une que le quart des
malades qui sont traités dans les
centres anti cancer
les autres sont traitées soit dans des
cliniques soient dans des hôpitaux
généraux et ce qu'il faut faire c'est
faire en sorte que dans ces cliniques
que dans ces hôpitaux généraux y ait les
mêmes équipes aussi compétente qu'il y
ait les mêmes instruments aussi
performants que nous avons actuelle dans
les centres les plus évolué c'est
possible puisque certains hôpitaux
certaines cliniques ont déjà atteint ce
point mais il faut un gros effort pour
que touche eric pour faire du bien à
jour merci
prenez le concert des vitesses est
d'ailleurs le type du premier numéro de
la nouvelle formule de vivre le journal
de la ligue nationale contre le cancer
la politique comme nous le laissions
entendre hier soir avec noël copain un
appel aujourd'hui de 70 communiste et
ancien communiste pour voter au second
tour de l'élection pour le candidat la
gauche qui sera arrivé en tête 26 avril
on y retrouve le nom de catherine
clément et de nombreux intellectuels en
situation délicate par rapport au pc
jacques dominati se perd et du tarot
rapatrier profondément indigné par la
proposition d'une amnistie totale pour
les anciens partisans de l'algérie
française une proposition de jacques
chirac
le candidat du rpr dit il fait preuve
d'un certain mépris vis-à-vis des
rapatriés comme s'il ne se souvenait pas
qu'il avait voulu me chasser du
gouvernement parce que j'en faisais trop
pour eux et puis le commentaire du
socialiste laurent fabius sur les
propositions gouvernementales en matière
d'emploi un chômeur de plus tous les
trois minutes
mais valéry giscard d'estaing c'est
monsieur chômage alors justement
essayons de voir avec la cma hinault
segré sont les programmes des différents
courants principaux de la vie politique
française dans ce domaine à deux mois
tout juste des élections
les propositions faites en matière
d'emploi par les quatre grands courants
politiques repose sur des analyses
différentes pour raymond barre l'une des
raisons essentielles du chômage est le
déséquilibre démographique qu'il faut
donc prendre des mesures temporaires en
attendant que d'ici 1984 85 le nombre de
départs à la retraite équilibre
l'arrivée des jeunes ce n'est pas
suffisant répond monsieur chirac qui se
dit convaincu que les chefs d'autres
prise ne recrute plus parce qu'ils
étouffent sous les règlements
administratifs et sous le poids de la
fiscalité pour faire disparaître le
chômage estime-t-il il faut redonner
confiance aux entreprises
françois mitterrand bien sûr fait
beaucoup moins confiance au secteur
privé son plan pour l'emploi passe par
un fort recrutement du secteur public et
par une relance de l'activité économique
une démarche que l'on retrouve dans le
programme de monsieur marché mais qui
serait amplifié par une croissance
économique plus forte
catherine 8% et par une relance plus
vives de la consommation voilà donc pour
les quatre philosophie elles se
traduisent par des propositions
concernant d'une part la fonction
publique et d'autre part le secteur
privé tout le monde est d'accord pour
recruter de nouveaux fonctionnaires sauf
monsieur chirac qui vous savez souhaite
que l'on ne remplace plus que la moitié
des agents de l'état partant à la
retraite
tout le monde est d'accord mais avec des
nuances importantes ainsi hier raymond
barre a simplement proposé 50 mille
emplois à temps partiel en illustration
alors que françois mitterrand veut créer
cent cinquante mille emplois à temps
plein dans le secteur public et georges
marchais 140000 secteur privé maintenant
le gouvernement va demander au patronat
l'engagement d'offrir au moins cent
mille emplois à temps partiel il va
susciter à titre temporaire
l'abaissement de l'âge du départ en
retraite jacques chirac de son côté veut
supprimer la taxe professionnelle et
assouplir les conditions de licenciement
pour que les deux millions de petites et
moyennes entreprises se remettent à
embaucher
françois mitterrand propose une
réduction des charges sociales des
entreprises manoeuvre
ils comptent aussi et surtout sur nos
lance de l'économie par un relèvement
des bas revenus
puis propose également une réduction du
temps de travail
enfin monsieur marc chef parvenir au
plein emploi en créant chaque année deux
cent soixante mille postes nouveaux dans
l'industrie cela serait permis à la fois
par une forte relance de la consommation
avec un smic porter immédiatement à 3300
francs et par une réduction à 35 heures
de la semaine de travail
oui dans le textile on a appris que le
groupe dollfus mig allait réduire cette
année ses effectifs de près de 13 cents
personnes et que dans l'automobile chez
peugeot selon le syndicat en aller
une journée supplémentaire de chômage
technique en mars 2011 encore une
croissance de 1 5% l'année dernière pour
la france et ce que nous apprend l'insee
et puis la situation de l'epargne s'est
améliorée au second trimestre 80 elle
avait été mauvais dans les six premiers
mois mais il y a quand même en tout un
recul de 20% par rapport à l'année
passée
enfin la banque paribas vient de rentrer
dans le groupe
enfin ce n'est une participation de 35%
le baron 20 a décidé de quitter la
présidence de schnell à l'étranger
d'abord toujours la situation en espagne
le roi a profité du putsch pour épurer
l'armée des éléments pro franquiste à ce
jour 22 officiers emprisonnés et un
général mis aux arrêts mais ils forment
que les ramifications sont beaucoup plus
profondes que cela le roi a reçu ce
matin le nouveau président du
gouvernement espagnol
léopold ii calvo sotelo qui devant lui
vous le voyez a prêté serment et puis
tout de suite après son prédécesseur
adolfo suarez que vous voyez au second
plan s'est vu honoré le roi lui a
conféré le titre de duc de suarez s'est
lui vous voyez à droite de l'image
et c'est ainsi que le duc a quitté
l'espagne pour un voyage de dix jours
aux états unis
alors au delà de l'anecdote il y à ce
fait majeur que représente l'unité du
peuple espagnol tout entier derrière son
roi même les communistes tout à l'heure
qui ont rendu un vibrant hommage
je pense que c'est important que moi
qu'ils soient qui ne suis pas royaliste
alice laloy a joué un rôle décisif pour
sauver la constitution voilà donc pour
le jugement du parti communiste espagnol
autre partie essentielle dans la crise
que vient de vivre l'espagne et qui
n'est sans doute pas terminée le parti
socialiste philippe gassot à rencontrer
son secrétaire général philippe hugon
thales qui venait d'essuyer un refus de
la part du nouveau premier ministre
monsieur calvo sotelo ne voulait pas de
socialistes dans son gouvernement et il
y à déjà parmi les forces armées et
parmi les forces de sécurité qui est
retourné la situation et situation
intérieure du franquisme
ça c'est ça c'est évident aussi qu'il
est la solution il y ait quoi que la
solution il faut encore c'était
tâche gouvernementale créée firme mais
avec beaucoup d'appuis populaires et par
la matière et c'est pas une discussion
parlementaire très large et c'est pas un
discours bien accompli c'est pas des
discussions mais monsieur est frappant
pour la société civile
cet hymne pas ce qu'il faut faire autour
d'une table il faut faire avec peu de
présence sans doute mais avec audace
aussi est ce que vous êtes pour une
épuration du mondial crois pas qu'on
doit employer et surtout en ce moment
les mots dépit ratio ou pas dureté ou
pas et quoi qu'il faut être efficace
quels sont selon vous les facteurs de
déstabilisation du pays on parle de
l'été à de l'économie et hiller bon dieu
pense d'eux et les grues guay ou autre
chose dit pas ce qu'il y à des facteurs
de déstabilisation du pays pas seulement
en espagne mais dans d'autres pays des
crises économiques des crises lady
terrorisme et quoique c'est une
explication pour les certains actes sud
les problèmes de terrorisme sans doute
les problèmes plus graves dans les pays
est beaucoup plus qu même que les
problèmes économiques et même s'il
affecte à moins d'être personne mais
j'ai craqué pour certaines personnes
même sans terrorisme sale état il y
aurait toujours l'intention de nous
faire rentrer au nouveau dans les
franquisme ne serez pas surpris
d'apprendre qu'on nivelle cesse leur
apporte de lénine brejnev a été approuvé
à l'unanimité et sans réserve par les
5000 délégués du parti communiste
soviétique réunis vous le savez depuis
lundi en congrès au delà donc tout
humour c'est un rapport qui fait le
bilan de l'économie et de la politique
soviétique des cinq dernières années et
qui fixe les grandes options du pays
jusqu'en 85 l'algérie plutôt pour
l'intervention libyenne au tchad dit le
président chadli qui refuse quand même
sa caution à une éventuelle fusion entre
la libye et le tchad
si ça ne correspond pas aux voeux des
deux peuples
la fin du voyage de jean paul ii en
extrême orient il a quitté le japon
après avoir parlé à tous
hiroshima et nagasaki c'est la
consomment c'est la première fois qu'un
patron d'être au japon pendant le voyage
de retour il a fait escale à anchorage
en alaska et dans la nuit il va repartir
pour rome certainement complètement
épuisé condamnation du leader
syndicaliste brésilien lula qui était en
france il n'y a pas si longtemps la cour
de justice militaire de san paolo l'a
condamné à trois ans et demi prison 12
de ses camarades ont également été
condamnés et puis atlanta deux nouveaux
enfants noirs âgés de 10 et 14 ans
portée disparue depuis un an et demi
la véritable traumatisme pour toutes les
familles noires de la ville 19 enfants
de couleur ont été retrouvés assassinés
les recherches ont déjà coûté cinq cent
mille dollars 2 millions de francs à la
ville
le président a galerie meem est
intervenu ni vient d'envoyer des
policiers fédéraux aurore jacques
viguier patrick derrien ont vécu pendant
quelques jours ce climat de psychose
patrick balthazard avait 11 ans il est
la dix neuvième victime d'une liste qui
s'allonge chaque jour des enfants noirs
entre 7 et 15 ans rien que des enfants
noirs dont on retrouve les corps dans
les bois du sud d'atlanta à l'église ce
jour là la représentante du maire dit
appelez nous appeler les journaux et
donnez nous toutes les informations que
vous pourrez glaner
c'est ici à la patinoire qu'on avait vu
le petit balthazar pour la dernière fois
à minuit le 6 février
ici même où on annonce que c'est me
davis viendra chanter le 10 mars au
profit des familles des enfants
pour endiguer la vague des meurtres le
couvre-feu à sept heures du soir a été
décrétée pour tous les enfants d'atlanta
cet étudiant de 16 ans i qu'il a quitté
new york il y a un an
en espérant que la vie atlanta serait
plus sûr aujourd'hui
atlanta est devenu aussi dangereuse que
new york conclut-il disparition
inexplicable de jour comme de nuit comme
le petit je ferais mathis disparus le 11
mars
80 j'ai peur du grand méchant nous avec
son revolver dit aujourd'hui un de ses
petits cousins
pendant que le grand frère de geoffrey
mathis explique que ce dernier est allé
un soir au coin de la rue acheter des
cigarettes
on a retrouvé son squelette la semaine
dernière de son côté la mère d'une
enfant de 12 ans explique que sa fille
était avec une petite copine c'était le
7 mars à 6 heures de l'après midi
trois jours après une amie de classe l'a
vu au supermarché
elle pleurait elle ne pouvait rien dire
et c'est le lendemain qu'on l'a retrouvé
mort et viol et les mères des victimes
en particulier reproche à la police
locale d'avoir attendu trop longtemps
dix mois avant de comprendre que tous
ces assassinats avait un lien entre eux
indifférence racisme ni l'un ni l'autre
mais une faute à deux pas de la tombe de
martin luther king le grand leader noir
on dit aussi que la sphère serait allé
plus vite si les enfants avait été blanc
on note que les enfants disparus sont
ceux des ghettos appartenant surtout à
des familles divisées
mais aussi des enfants très intelligente
des surdoué confronté avant l'âge au
problème des adultes mais notre pass
culture a suscité après une actualité
chargée six derniers temps de la chanson
ce soir et vous allez voir grâce à you
bagré loire et patrice du tertre que
même les chanteurs poètes en
l'occurrence maxime le forestier
s'accommode aujourd'hui la vitesse des
guitares électriques et du confort des
camping cars maxime le forestier qui a
repris la route
voilà deux ans qu'il avait abandonné la
scène
voici reparti pour une nouvelle aventure
effectivement un départ en tournée c'est
un peu une aventure des milliers de
kilomètre 42 villes en deux mois un
retour en force pour maxime le forestier
après une absence de deux ans
souvenez vous san francisco la petite
furent toutes ces chansons qui par leur
niveau et leur succès ont tracé la voie
à une génération de chanteurs comme les
8es ou autres unique ciment sable et de
cheveux longs
de grands lits et de vue dit que peuplée
de lumière et peuplée de fous elle sera
dernière à rester tout
ces scores c'est bon
san francisco
mon si vous êtes resté longtemps absent
parce que vous cherchiez
à faire des chansons qu'est ce qui vous
assure c'est pas mes chansons je vivais
partie vivre à la campagne j'ai voyagé
beaucoup
quand la magie qui démarre très peu
et puis j'avais pas envie de faire le
saltimbanque à ce moment là je vais
chose à faire
non j'ai envie de repartir je repars ça
c'est une chance que j'ai de pouvoir
hier ce que j'ai envie
ce qui regarde en arrière
voix
que donnant mon ciel
oui nous pluies d'automne un jour
m
cheveux mouillés
quand je serrais
ce soit
mais moi
sinon
souvenirs d'enfant
j'ai eu 30 ans je suis content
soit
si le forestier et à marseille jusque
samedi de nouveau mensuel font leur
apparition futur un mensuel de
science-fiction et de fantastique puis
antilles guyane actualité qui dit bien
ce qu'il veut représenter le quarté 8 12
15 et 18 je crois en tout cas vous
devriez voir apparaître voilà c'est des
m18 les rapports qui sont assez
conséquents 47520 francs dans l'ordre et
dans la halle ordre différent
sept mille neuf cent vingt ans il faut
que je vous dise que je viens
d'apprendre que le gagnant du loto qui
rayaient va remporter la somme record de
10 me lis un milliard de centimes tiers
10 millions de francs 10 millions de
francs d'aujourd'hui ça s'est passé à
toulon je pense pour connaître à son
identité en tout cas c'est assez
extraordinaire
la page météo maintenant alain
gillot-pétré ce redoux genre doubiens
côté avec l'aide de la météo je vous
avais annoncé lundi qu'il aurait le
redoux pour la fin de la semaine
nous sommes à la fin de la semaine et le
redoux arrive par l'ouest cela 10 à 13
heures il faisait encore frais notamment
au nord et au centre du pays - 1 à
bourges - 2 à lyon plus doux près de la
méditerranée et des côtes atlantiques la
situation métrologique général pour
demain l'anticyclone calme froid arrêt
stable s'en va les dépressions agité
arrive avec un front chaud et donneront
sur la france un temps humide et doux
jusqu'à dimanche au moins
en tout cas pour demain à l'ouest du
pays un temps très nuageux avec de la
pluie à vent de sud à sud-est force si
c'est à dire assez fort à fort - nuages
et au pays basque où le temps sera plus
doux cahier vert il y aura de la neige
sur les pyrénées de là encore s'il
pleuvra
le vent sera de sud à sud est près du
littoral méditerranéen et sur le reste
du pays après dissipation des brumes et
brouillards matinaux et brouillards
givrants le temps sera variable avec de
belles éclaircies notamment l'après midi
pour samedi maintenant l'ensemble du
pays sera très nuageux avec des averses
orageuses près de la méditerranée où le
vent continuera à souffler du sud à
sud-ouest au nord-est par contre vous le
voyez encore un temps variable et frais
avec quelques chutes éparses de neige et
à l'ouest le vent tournera à l'ouest il
sera encore assez fort à fort mais le
temps sera variable avec quelques
averses les températures pour demain
nous avons simplifié aujourd'hui au nom
centré et hausse à l'ouest et au sud au
nord - 2 le matin + 7 en moyenne au
centre - 4 le matin +6 l'après-midi à
l'ouest et au sud + 3 le matin + 11
l'après midi c'est leur double dimanche
30 ans à 15 degrés et plus au sud de la
france l'enneigement puisque nous sommes
jeudi sur le massif des vosges du jura
et du massif central la neige est
excellente partout pour les skieurs
surtout au jura pour les alpes du nord
et du centre pas de problème c'est tout
bon pour les skieurs mais aux alpes du
sud un déficit de 55 cm à 2500 mètres ce
n'est pas beaucoup pour les pyrénées pas
de problème aussi c'est de la poudre
comme disent les skieurs excellent
partout demain petit agenda habituel
demain le soleil se lèvera à 7h38
souffre à 18h29 remettront sainte
honorine sainte-honorine qui est la
patronne de la batellerie j'ai été vite
mais la dépression arrive au galop à
l'actif de dsi sur la corse ou sujet
remarquer tout cela dernier rendez-vous
l'actualité avec hervé claude vers 23h15
demain en seine 2010 et en recevra jean
françois bizot le directeur d'actuels
mensuel très attachant et puis nous
retrouvons à 20 heures si vous voulez
bien bonsoir à tous